hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the issues that John Cassian
clearly feels needs to be dealt with
gotten out of the way at the very
beginning of chapter 8 of his institutes
is a kind of argument that is going to
be made and he actually calls this a
most pernicious disease of the Soul
namely anger people are trying to excuse
it in such a way as to Endeavor to
extenuate it to make excuses for it by a
rather shocking way of interpreting
scripture so people must have been
making these arguments quite often for
him to think that it's important
remember too that the institutes are
directed not just at everybody but
specifically at people living and
devoted to a monastic life so even
within the monasteries this must have
been coming up people will argue that
there's a kind of example being provided
about anger so anger is not not
necessarily bad or wrong why not well
because the scriptures say that God
himself
rages so the word there is this is
pretty common for Cassian to be tying
these two together or God gets angry
so either God is getting irritated and
angry or God is like totally out of
control with his anger and
they say you know if if you know God can
get angry like that then it's not
injurious knocks us right if we are
angry with the Brethren who do wrong so
you know it doesn't excuse all anger
it's saying that when our fellow monks
or our fellow human beings screw up ah
you know God gets angry at them so why
can't we human beings get angry and
there's a lot of examples being provided
within scripture casting is just
surveying probably the most commonly
brought up he says that the anger of God
the anger of the Lord was kindled
against his people that said many many
times right or the prophet prays and
says Lord rebuke me not in thine anger
nor chasten me in thy displeasure and so
you know when these things are being
said like that it's kind of natural that
a lot of people well God does get angry
and think about the way in which people
people talk to each other particularly
like parents to children oh you better
behave or God's gonna get mad at you
right mad like I do so the question then
is well how should we understand this
and Cassian brings up two ways of
understanding those very names we could
say two different ways of understanding
the same mistaken approach he talks
about a literal approach to scripture
sequentum
and you know this means taking the
things that are said in their absolute
literate sense and then he says well
that gives you something that is as
translated here gross and material
cardinali at pingui right so something
that is fleshly and something that is
painted something that is depicted
that's not the right way to be looking
at these matters these are some things
you do want to be literal about other
things perhaps you don't and a little
bit later on he's going to say and he's
going to use a Greek term here we should
understand these passages not
anthropol pathos so apothos means
emotion right and anthropo means human
so we should not understand these
attributions of anger or rage or
whatever to God in a way that's you
could say modeled after human emotions
instead
um you know we should think of it in
terms of how God if God is angry how God
would be angry so he says this is to
look at it according to the Unworthy
meaning of human passion and the
Unworthy there is humili's right so the
word we get humility from the lowly so
we're not supposed to be you know
understanding these references to Divine
anger in that way and Cassian is going
to go on and say listen if you're you're
going to apply this logic to the
references to anger well what about all
the other places in scripture where we
see things attributed to God that we
know can't really be correct at least
interpreted in a literal sense and he's
going to give you plenty of examples of
this from scripture so he says listen if
you're going to buy into this God raging
then you know it's also said that God
sleeps for instance arise wherefore
sleep is thou O Lord now does the
Creator and maintainer of the universe
this Transcendent being go to sleep
every once in a while no so there must
be some other way to understand that
um says you know behold he who keepeth
Israel shall neither slumber nor sleep
right so even on a literal level in that
we don't we don't have a god sleeping
what about God standing and sitting he
stands and sits since he says Heaven is
my seat and the Earth the footstool for
my feet though he measure out the heaven
with his hand he holdeth the Earth in
his fist
um
these aren't really appropriate these
are metaphorical
constructions right part of poetry
really and then he he goes out and he
talks about other interesting cases does
God get drunk well there's you know
he is drunken with wine as it is said
the Lord awoke like a sleeper a mighty
man drunken with wine so that makes it
sound like God uh tied one on and you
know had a bender and then had to
recover from it or
um
what about ignorance or forgetfulness we
find mention of these in the Holy
Scripture you know God doesn't know for
example that the Tower of babbles being
built and he's like surprised when he
comes on it and he's like wow what is
this what are they going to do next in
saying what are they going to do next
implies that God doesn't know so you
know you can find scriptural instances
about these what about God having a body
you know he goes on at the end of this
this third chapter and he says we often
find mention mentioned in the Holy
scriptures of the outline of his limbs
which are spoken of as arranged and
ordered like a human beings the hair
head nostrils eyes face hands arms
fingers belly and feet if we're willing
to take all of which according to the
bear literal sense then we must think of
God as in fashion with the outline of
Limbs in a bodily form and he says Ah
this can't be right so what he's doing
here is he's again saying saying if
you're going to buy into this logic of
well scripture says that God gets mad so
therefore God does get mad why don't you
believe all these other things that
scripture is saying at a literal level
about God that we say are totally
inappropriate to God so then what would
be the right interpretation of these
sorts of matters he tells us that we
should understand that God is free from
all human passions per tabatzio is the
word that he's using there and that's
the word that he was using before and
talking about the Unworthy meaning of
human passion
means a a bad passion the kinds of
things that drive us that shake us anger
being one of them so he's going to go on
with this right interpretation if God is
really free from all passion how should
we understand
attributing anger to God he says we
should we should look at God as being
the judge and Avenger of all unjust
things which are done in the world and
by reason of these terms and their
meaning we should dread him as the
terrible rewarder of our deeds and fear
to do anything against his will no he
takes that back a little bit and he says
when you come before the judge if you're
actually like pure and clean and you
haven't done anything wrong well then
you don't have to fear
how many of us does that apply to not
not an awful lot so you know we should
look at God as being one who takes
action in this this world and in the
life to come as well and he goes on and
he says human nature is want to fear
those who it knows to be indignant right
to indignar to get angry and uh afraid
of offending as in the case of some most
judge judges
those who are worrying about avenging
wrath are those who've done stuff wrong
right and this is very interesting here
because he's not saying well you know
God does these things and everybody
should take them as being avenging wrath
but in in a metaphorical sense he's
actually saying that
the way that this gets interpreted is
largely a function of how screwed up how
unjust we actually are
so he tells us here that God is you know
executing his his law impartially and he
says whatever kindness and gentleness
with which it may be conducted it is
deemed by those who are justly to be
punished
to be the most Savage wrath and vehement
anger so it's not everybody necessarily
who sees God's judgments or God's
actions or the you know retribution
that's being taken on people for unjust
actions and says oh wow God's anger
right some people are like God's
kindness he's uh you know fixing things
here but those who have been doing the
wrong thing are most likely to see this
as most Savage wrath and vehemence anger
on the part of the one who is
administering justice so this is how
latencius thinks we ought to look at
these references to Divine anger God
doesn't feel the passion of anger like
we human beings do or be he's not driven
by anger but it's something that appears
angrily to those who have trained
transgressed and that can include
basically all of us more or less again
he's writing this to monks who are
paying closer attention to their souls
perhaps than other people are and so
there's no justification coming from
this for us getting angry because we
don't even feel the sort of thing that
God would the references to Divine anger
are not references according to Cassian
to something that is like the anger that
we feel and experience instead it's just
referring to you might say God's very
goodness and justice